first ballot hall-of-famer John Smoltz
how are you John good thanks for having
me do better as always what does
pitchers and catchers report mean to you
what's your favor
what does that mean when you hear those
words John you know for all those years
that I used to look at the guys before
me like Nolan Ryan 27 spring trainings
whatever it was some ungodly number I
used to think how many spring trainings
can I go to and each time we showed up
will I have my fastball because you just
you you go through the years we did in
the postseason and all the lack of rest
and all that and every year I would come
to spring training just going okay I've
done my work do I have my fastball this
year and on behold every year I would
have my fastball so those are the things
the pitcher thinks about from time to
time besides the normal just I want to
be healthy but it's the first two weeks
no matter what you've done where you've
done it it's different when you get
there and for a lot of guys who don't
have the luxury of training outdoors
it's a big difference from the indoor
workouts to the outdoor workouts so just
showing out what I love how you
mentioned Nolan Ryan did you ever wind
up in a I mean who are you in a in a
spring training camp with early on that
you looked at like wow okay that's an
old-time great I'm going to learn from
him or just any story that you have from
back in that day you know I was always
admiring the guys we had early on we
were trying to be young and trying to
figure out how to win we lived in a
hundred games every year there wasn't a
lot to look up to when when you're going
to spring training going
gosh can we finish anywhere but last
then guys like Charlie Leibrandt Terry
Pendleton said bringing veterans that
had won somewhere else that you could
just pick their brains that they would
have you know the ability to give you
insights that's what I gravitated
towards I wanted to know what it was
like to win I never thought we were
going to win for the longest time and
then getting a taste of that being able
to pass on the baton to the younger guys
and just knowing the ins and outs of
spring training it was a veteran knowing
he didn't have to make the club you're
just working on your craft and then not
to mention we had the greatest spring
training in the history of baseball and
the greatest manager
so getting there i want your tee times
were certain times getting them get into
play till 36 18 holes get you work in
get your work out and go have fun the
rest a day whether it's at Magic Kingdom
or making birdies somewhere on a cockle
so now did Bobby Cox really match things
up with your teat on John Doe not
actually happen here's just here's this
think about look I watch films today
even on our network i watch I've seen
workouts from the players and clubs that
I have no idea what that is
none none ever ran with parachutes never
jumped hurdles never did any of the
things never picked up a tractor tire
never did any of those things and we
just kept it to the nuts and bolts Bobby
said get in do your work and get out if
you're diligent and you do the things
I've asked you to do
go have fun the rest of the day I'm not
going to keep here to keep you here for
nonsense and it was it was brilliant and
anybody who came from another team it
took him two weeks to get over the fact
that they said seriously this is all we
get to do we don't we don't have any of
these time killer stuff and I we would
tell him do your work most of the work
that we got done was where nobody saw it
in the training room in the weight room
in the cages then we'd go out and throw
for a limited time and we didn't stay in
shag like you know to kill time and then
we got in a car went to of course and at
the time of our lives I love it so
you're looking at some of the spring
training exercises right now under what
laughs yeah it has nothing to do with
baseball I mean the training the guys
are doing today is so in my opinion over
the top and not sports specific it's why
injuries are at the highest level it's
why these guys look like they should be
on some bodybuilding show instead of
standing on the mound or standing at
home plate the bodies are phenomenal and
I wouldn't say a word if the injury rate
was cut in half but it hasn't it's gone
the other way and so when you're
literally when you're lifting a big huge
tractor tire what part of that has
anything to do with baseball at no point
do you ever simulate or duplicate that
motion play
baseball but there's smarter people I
guess to me out there that hope it to
play half of the spring trainings that
I've gone to and think that that's good
enough
John you sound like another Hall of Fame
Atlanta brave just a different Hall of
Fame and Deion Sanders he says every
year at the combine when when they show
the defensive backs try to lift to
twenty five in the weight and reps room
at the combine Dion laughs and he goes I
don't understand why they make them do
this he said I never had to put Jerry
Rice across my chest and lift him ten
times he's exactly right and I think you
know we've evolved in a smarter
generation there's no doubt there's more
knowledge there's more technology guys
are bigger stronger faster but we have
not adapted to the sports specific items
that you need to be for a particular
position you might be able to get away
with it if you're an offense alignment
defense alignment but the Dion's point a
specialty position that recreates
quickness speed and and agility the same
thing with pitching you know pitchers
never have looked the way they have
looked before but never have they not
lasted you know I think that's something
we keep turning a deaf ear to and you
know why we do it because the philosophy
of there are more coming and we can just
replenish the deck well I'm here to tell
you that at some point that point of no
return is going to happen and clubs are
going to have to go back and refigure
out how they're going to redevelop their
farm system and their ball clubs to last
the entire year instead of the shuttle
back and forth with you young minor
leaguers that come up for two weeks and
eat up those innings that the other guys
can't John Smoltz here on the verge of
pitchers and catchers reporting in
baseball is there a a collusion issue do
you think John is there so what cuz I
mean we're seeing a bunch of I mean free
agents that are not signed baseball how
to put out a statement about a week ago
saying this is just normal business
practices well what do you think is
happening in the fact is a couple things
never have we seen that the amount of
teams going into severe opposite
directions when you unload your young
talent controllable talents from three
different teams you are clogging the the
free agent market because it's cheaper
to get those guys than it
is to spend that money on what you
normally would to add on a great player
that makes a difference in your team
some of these guys have already turned
down some pretty good contracts looking
to get more more years more money is not
out there right now for the sense of I
talked about being smarter seven and
eight year contracts just don't
typically work or they haven't and some
of the injuries that we talked about you
get a point in overturned once you get
that late in the contract and the team
is in a different direction so I think
it's a perfect storm unfortunately for
players that all have fallen into this
boat and cause some have misread the
market from their agent standpoint and
you know let's face it some have turned
down some pretty good money already
think they were gonna get more so not
all of the players are lost in the same
group but some of the marquee guys that
we would expect it to already go like a
JD Martinez or Jake Arrieta or some of
those in the past years of what you've
taken this long so look it's it is truly
a perfect storm I don't think collusion
it's an easy word to throw out there
because it's happened in the past but I
don't believe taking the emotions out is
that's the big culprit and pitch clock
what's your take on this we're gonna
we're seeing it right I mean this is
happening and we're gonna see it and
how's that gonna manifest itself this
season well first and foremost
everything that's coming down the pipe
is enticing the players to just play the
game a little faster because they
they've played it to a dull roar it's
not the game we once used to see and
know there's too much information
there's too many pitching changes this
is only gonna make such a small dent
players are not going to notice this
once they get accustomed to it it might
affect 2% of the entire players in the
game who physically might not be able to
throw a pitch in 18 seconds or less and
that's just kind of gonna have to be too
bad you're gonna have to learn you're
gonna have to adjust there's nothing
that will affect the game short of
changing the ball changing the equipment
and changing the bats we talk way too
much about these kind of changes for the
good of the game players will adapt
players are always going to be great at
whatever they do they're just going to
find whatever it is that makes them
comfortable
and these kind of things have been too
comfortable a bit too long coming that
the game and and the crux of it is look
all these might shave 3 to 5 minutes off
of a game time which is important but
the reality is if you allow teams to
make 9 pitching changes again and have
these mid and pitching changes happening
between two teams that is where the game
slows down at some point we got to
figure out a way to affect the strategy
of the game in mid aiding pitching
changes because is you see an all-star
game or you see the amount of pitchers
that pitch in an all-star game
granted it's an exhibition when you have
9 or 7 different pitchers catch an
inning and finish the inning the game
doesn't slow down at all
and so even it's not about how many
pitch per game its how many come in the
middle of an inning 8 listening you know
on one batter at a time not getting it
out or not fitting you know that the the
7th inning of the famous Washington
Nationals Dodgers playoff game I think
it was an hour and 45 minutes I mean
that can't happen you know at Granite
that's the playoffs but it's happening
so much in regular season game I think
the Commissioner looks long-term to say
we've got to make sure that fans are not
turning their attention to something
else because the games are lasted too
long
and lastly John Smoltz I'm loath to ask
this because you know obviously what
Houston have to happen to it last year
was a perfect storm that required Justin
Verlander to be acquired
late season but is it a yankee dodger
prediction going into the season for you
John no I don't think so at all I think
the that the Astros have got better I
think everything that they did last year
the necessity necessary moves they made
certainly spoke for itself winning a
world championship they went out and
addressed their issues and got better
it's going through Houston no matter
what anyone says there's a team to beat
but there's some really good teams
everyone's forgetting about Boston
Boston did not have David Price last
year they're going to have of this year
they've got Chris Sale yes could they
add an offensive punch to their lineup
to make a difference that time will tell
the Yankees no doubtedly have one of the
sexiest most intriguing lineup
to watch but their swings and misses in
that lineup so it's gonna be a great
American League campaign not to mention
Cleveland and the likes of Minnesota so
I think anybody would say that Houston
has gotten better Houston is the team to
beat and it's going to be fun to watch
these guys go after it and
internationally do not sleep in my
opinion do not sleep on the San
Francisco Giants no one's given them any
thought at all that's true but they can
be back in the mix with the Dodgers I
personally think they will why I think
that last year everything that could go
long did go along Bumgarner's injury and
again the health of him is going to be
so important they address some of their
outfield needs everyone's assessing the
San Francisco Giants as old these are
analytic people who push numbers through
a computer determining age I just once
want to go up to one of these guys and
go your shelf life on computer is about
three more years get it done they don't
understand what a club goes through and
the injury aspect of it yes trends point
the San Francisco Giants going into
wrong direction but they're a proud
organization they've addressed some aids
that got Longoria kuchen Jackson they
bake they made an addition list of
pitching I think again the San Francisco
Giants are going to sneak up on some
teams and be right there right there in
the playoffs deciding this is all great
John it's all great I love our chats as
always my god Chris Brockman is a big
Red Sox guy you know I'm a Yankee guy
the odds at the Yankees at some point
this season last one for you will have a
10 run lead over the Red Sox at any
point during the season in any game what
would you give the odds on that because
we're trying to figure out what we
should place on the line run lead in one
game at any point correct
you think yeah I think you know with the
way that things can go awry those are
highs you would think because they got
such often they're gonna beat up on bad
pitching so there's going to be times
where in this great rivalry that's
coming back by the way the Red Sox or
the Yankees I think are officially back
as that rivalry that we all came to know
you know I would say there are 10 to 15
to 1 where where that could happen
if the game gets away from the Red Sox
because of the offensive power that the
Yankees have so I it's not as high as
one would think
I think there's a there's a chance that
could happen John Smoltz playing the
role of Danny Sheridan in this situation
between me and Rahman
great chatting with you John we'll chat
again soon hopefully that's John Smoltz
MLB Network Fox Sports the Rich Eisen
show weekdays at noon eastern on
audience